This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you're walking in San Francisco, you might not know when you're crossing from the western addition neighborhood into Hayes Valley, or if you're in Portola or Excelsior, but you could be aimlessly wandering around any western city of significant size, including San Francisco or Oakland, and you'll know exactly when you're in Chinatown. Those visual cues may be simple to pick up on, but it turns out the origin stories of Chinatown and the architecture and food that come from it are far more complex and interesting than you can imagine.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马斯。如果你在旧金山散步，你可能分不清自己是什么时候从西部加利福尼亚街区走到海斯谷的，或者你是在波托拉还是埃尔塞索区；但你可以漫无目的地在任何一个有规模的美国西部城市闲逛，包括旧金山或奥克兰，而当你身处中国城时，你会一眼就能认出来。这些视觉线索或许很容易捕捉，但事实证明，中国城的起源故事以及源自那里的建筑和美食，远比你想象的要复杂得多、有趣得多。
We did a couple stories on this a few years ago and we've compiled them together into this episode. I hope you like it. In 1968, George Soi stepped off a plane from Hong Kong and into the San Francisco International Airport. It was his first time on American soil. At 22 years old, he had left his homeland of China and traveled across the ocean to build a new life for himself and his young life in this land of opportunity. When immigrants first come to the US and this is such an old trope and an old story that you expect, you know, the streets are paved with gold.
几年前我们做过几个相关的报道，现在我们将它们汇编成了这一集。希望你们会喜欢。1968年，佐治·崔（George Soi）走下从香港飞来的飞机，踏入了旧金山国际机场。这是他第一次踏上美国土地。22岁时，他离开了祖国中国，跨越大洋，在这片充满机遇的土地上为自己和年轻的生活开启新的人生。当移民初次来到美国时——这是一种如此陈旧的老套路和旧故事，以至于你会期待——你知道的，这里的街道是用黄金铺就的。
This is Bonnie Toy, George's daughter. She's also the author of a book about American Chinatowns. Even today, Chinese people still call San Francisco Gumson, meaning gold mountain. This is where you find your fortune in San Francisco. George Toys very first stop in San Francisco. His very first stop in America, like a generation upon generation of Chinese immigrants before him, was San Francisco's Chinatown. And he was not impressed.
这是邦妮·崔，佐治的女儿。她也是一本关于美国中国城书籍的作者。直到今天，中国人和华侨仍然把旧金山叫做“金山”，意思是黄金之山。这就是你在旧金山发财的地方。佐治·崔在旧金山的落脚点。他来到美国的第一个落脚点，就像在他之前的一代又一代中国移民一样，是旧金山的中国城。但他并没有留下深刻的印象。
To George San Francisco's Chinatown felt out of date. All the things he saw in Chinatown, these pagoda roofs, these dragon gates, these flourishes that, you know, to us signal China and Chinese-ness, they were things that he actually hadn't seen in back in China for years and years and years and years, and they were not used in that architectural vernacular back there. And so he wondered how Chinatown in this, you know, really supposedly modern America was why did it feel older than the oldest parts of Hong Kong where he grew up? Because it was designed that way. That's producer Chelsea Davis.
对佐治来说，旧金山的中国城感觉很过时。他在中国城看到的所有东西——那些宝塔式的屋顶、那些龙门、那些在我们看来象征着中国和中国风味的繁复装饰——其实是他回到中国后已经很多很多年都没有见过的东西，而且那里在建筑白话中并不使用这些。所以他想知道，为什么在这个所谓真正现代的美国里的中国城，会比他长大的香港最古老的地方还要显得古老呢？因为它是被设计成这样的。那是制作人切尔西·戴维斯。
For George Soi and many other Chinese immigrants, San Francisco's Chinatown and the Chinatowns in a lot of American cities, they don't look much like the China they know. It looks like a bit of a movie set actually. It's so out of context to anything else next to it on either side. That's filmmaker Felicia Lowe. She made a documentary about San Francisco's Chinatown. Walking around Chinatown together, we passed Bank of America E.T.M.s guarded by gold dragons, shops with neon lit names like Heart of Shanghai, selling paper fans and plastic booties,
对佐治·崔和许多其他中国移民来说，旧金山市的中国城以及许多美国城市的中国城，看起来并不太像他们所了解的中国。它实际上看起来有点像电影布景。它与两侧的其他任何东西都格格不入。那是电影制片人菲利西亚·洛。她制作了一部关于旧金山中国城的纪录片。我们一起漫步在中国城，路过了由金龙守护的美国银行自动取款机，挂着诸如“上海之心”等霓虹灯招牌的商店，里面出售着纸扇和塑料小短靴，
and towering four-story bazaars crowned with little pagodas. But Chinatown hasn't always looked this way. In fact, before the massive earthquake that leveled San Francisco in 1906, Chinatown looked like most of the other neighborhoods in San Francisco. Rose of Brick Holmes, done up with Victorian Italianate Fessons. The only thing you recognize is Chinatown are the people in it. And the Chinese signs, instead of American signs.
以及头顶饰有小宝塔的高耸四层集市。但中国城并非一直都是这个样子的。事实上，在1906年将旧金山夷为平地的特大地震之前，中国城看起来就像旧金山的绝大多数其他社区一样。一排排红砖住宅，饰有维多利亚意大利式的饰面。唯一能让你认出那是中国城的东西，是里面的人。以及中文招牌，而不是英文招牌。
That's Phil Choi, a retired architect and historian of Chinese American culture. He grew up in San Francisco's Chinatown and still lives there today. He says it's not like Chinese immigrants in SF had strong opinions either way about their neighborhood's Victorian flourishes, the columns, the porches.
那是菲尔·崔，一位退休建筑师和美国华人文化历史学家。他在旧金山的中国城长大，至今仍住在那里。他说，这并不是说旧金山的中国移民对他们社区的维多利亚式装饰、柱子和门廊有什么强烈的个人看法。
They just didn't have much choice when it came to where they lived. After arriving in America, they moved into the old homes that white people had abandoned for greener pastures. And after that, basically the Chinese didn't have time to really pay attention to the architecture or creating Chinese architecture. The basic desire was to make a living. And making a living was easier said than done if you were Chinese in early 20th century San Francisco. Since the 1860s Chinese immigrants had been a
当涉及到他们居住的地方时，他们只是没有太多选择。来到美国后，他们搬进了白人为了更广阔天地而抛弃的老房子。在那之后，基本上中国人没有时间真正去关注建筑或创造中国建筑。最基础的愿望就是谋生。如果你是20世纪初旧金山的华裔，谋生说起来容易做起来难。自19世纪60年代以来，中国移民一直是一个
convenient scapegoat for nationwide job shortages. The result was federal legislation like the 1882 Chinese Exclusion Act, which barred the vast majority of Chinese people from entering the states, and made it impossible for Chinese already in the U.S. to become new American citizens. In San Francisco, racist housing policies made it almost impossible for people of Chinese heritage to live outside of Chinatown. And when they did set foot outside the 15 square blocks of the Chinese enclave, it was at the risk of physical violence. So the self-contained world of Chinatown served as a desperately needed refuge for Chinese Sanfansisquins.
全国性工作短缺的替罪羊。其结果是出台了诸如1882年《排华法案》之类的联邦立法，该法案禁止绝大多数中国人进入美国，并使已经在美国的中国人无法成为新的美国公民。在旧金山，种族主义住房政策使得华裔几乎不可能在中国城之外的地方居住。而当他们确实踏出这15个街区的华人聚居区时，就要冒着遭受暴力袭击的风险。因此，自给自足的中国城世界为旧金山华裔提供了一个急需的避难所。
But in 1906, that refuge would be eviscerated by a double whammy of a disaster. Early in the morning of April 18th of that year, San Francisco's woke up to a 7.8 magnitude earthquake. It was the biggest quake in the city's recorded history. Still is, but those violent tremors were just the beginning. Because the earthquake shattered the city's gas mains and the gas that leaked out, somewhere it connected with a spark.
但在1906年，这个避难所将被双重灾难彻底摧毁。当年4月18日清晨，旧金山人醒来时遭遇了里氏7.8级的大地震。这是该市有记载历史上最大的一次地震。现在依然如此，但那些剧烈的震颤只是个开始。因为地震震碎了城市的燃气主管道，泄漏出来的燃气在某个地方接触到了火花。
The massive fires that resulted lasted for three days and destroyed about 500 city blocks. Chinatown was one of the first neighborhoods to go up and smoke. The safe space for Chinese release that 15 block radius of the neighborhood and without it, it becomes a very dangerous situation. Andrea Davies is a historian at the Stanford Humanities Center. But before her career in academia, she was in a slightly different line of work. I was a San Francisco firefighter for about five years, and so my first assignment was trying to down.
随之产生的大火持续了三天，摧毁了大约500个城市街区。中国城是首批化为灰烬的社区之一。华人的安全空间，也就是该社区那15个街区的半径，一旦失去，就会变成一个非常危险的状况。安德烈娅·戴维斯是斯坦福人文学中心的历史学家。但在她的学术生涯之前，她从事着一份略有不同的工作。“我曾做过大约五年的旧金山消防员，所以我的第一个任务就是试着去扑灭……”
Fighting fires in that neighborhood later led Davies to write a social history of the 1906 catastrophe. She says that in the wake of the disaster, newspapers peddled this feel-goodie story that the SF Quake and Fire were social equalizers, that the shared experience of suffering, united San Francisco's of all colors and creeds, man helping man, and so on. But while white men may have helped white man, no one was up in the Chinese. And in fact, the racism against them only intensified. I call it heightened post-disaster racism.
在该社区灭火的经历后来促使戴维斯撰写了一部关于1906年灾难的社会史。她表示，灾难过后，报纸兜售着这种让人感觉良好的故事，宣称旧金山地震和火灾是社会平等器，苦难的共同经历将各种肤色和信仰的旧金山人团结在一起，守望相助，诸如此类。但虽然白人可能帮助了白人，却没有人去管中国人。事实上，针对他们的种族主义反而加剧了。我称之为加剧的灾后种族主义。
You could see this heightened racism happening on at least two levels. First, with individual white San Francisco's. The built environment keeps everyone in their place. And that's what gets erased on April 18, 1986. So if you're an elite white San Francisco, you don't have to see the residents of Chinatown issue go there.
你可以看到这种加剧的种族主义在至少两个层面上发生。首先，针对个别的旧金山白人。建成环境让每个人各安其位。而这正是1906年4月18日被抹去的东西。所以，如果你是一个精英白人旧金山人，你就不必去看到中国城的居民，也不必去那里。
As the Chinese are leaving their homes in desperation, they're being yelled at to get out and don't turn back. And according to Davies, it wasn't just private citizens who were guilty of that heightened racism, because the second place that the fire spurred a flare-up in racism was in how the recovery efforts were managed. The fire department did very little to stop it in Chinatown and in fact made it worse. And the water mains have broken, so it is not one enough water to fight the fires. As if you look at Chinatown, which is nestled right against Naube Hill, where all the elite mansions are, all the water goes directly by the mayor to save Naube Hill.
当中国人在绝望中离开他们的家园时，他们被大喊着滚出去，并且不准回头。据戴维斯所说，并非只有平民百姓才犯下这种加剧的种族主义，因为火灾激化种族主义的第二个地方在于救援工作的管理方式。消防部门几乎没有采取什么措施来阻止中国城的火灾，事实上反而使其变得更糟。水管已经破裂了，所以没有足够的水来灭火。如果你看看中国城，它紧挨着诺布山，那里是所有精英豪宅所在的地方，所有的水都直接绕过市长流向诺布山，以拯救诺布山。
And all the dynamite goes into Chinatown. At the time, fire departments would dynamite buildings to keep fire from spreading. But the fire department used the wrong kind of dynamite, and Chinatown burned all the faster. In the following days, as the embers of Chinatown cooled, the Chinese found themselves homeless, and newly vulnerable in hostile streets. But things were about to get worse. So many of the city's political and business leaders were actually excited about this social equalizing disaster because it eliminated Chinatown and they thought we'll never rebuild it. Before the quake, many whites had seen the Chinese neighborhood as a
所有的炸药都被运进了中国城。当时，消防部门会用炸药炸毁建筑物以防止火势蔓延。但消防部门使用了错误的炸药，导致中国城烧得更快了。在接下来的几天里，随着中国城余烬渐熄，华人们发现自己流离失所，并在充满敌意的街道上变得更加脆弱。但情况将会变得更糟。该市的许多政治和商业领袖实际上对这场具有社会平等化作用的灾难感到兴奋，因为它消灭了中国城，他们认为我们再也不会重建它了。地震前，许多白人一直将华人社区视为一个
Gamora of opium dens, prostitution and disease. In 1885, City Hall had prepared a municipal report on Chinatown, and in that report, pages of documentation listing all the houses of prostitution and the number of gambling houses, and opium dens throughout Chinatown. This reputation for vice had actually created a minor industry of slum tourism in Chinatown. Thrills seeking white people could hire a guide to lead them through scenes of alleged depravity. They would be taken through dimly lit buildings and shown opium smokers and prostitutes
鸦片馆、卖淫和疾病的罪恶渊薮。1885年，市政府准备了一份关于中国城的市政报告，在该报告中，有几页的文件列出了中国城所有的妓院、赌场的数量以及鸦片馆。这种恶名实际上在中国城催生了一个小型贫民窟旅游产业。寻求刺激的白人可以雇佣导定向他们展示所谓的堕落场景。他们会被带过昏暗的建筑，观看吸食鸦片者、妓女
and gambling. Evidence suggests that some of these scenes may have actually been staged by the guides themselves. And one thing that was definitely fake was a widespread rumor that San Francisco's Chinese residents lived in underground tunnels. This is what they really believe that the Chinese lived underground. And even today, people want to see China Town's underground. On top of all this, China town was right in the middle of choice downtown real estate.
和赌博。有迹象表明，其中一些场景实际上可能是由导游自己策划的。而有一件绝对是假的事，那就是关于旧金山华人居民住在地下隧道的广泛谣言。这就是他们真正相信中国人住在地下。甚至在今天，人们还想去看看中国城的地下。最重要的是，中国城正位于繁华市中心黄金地段的正中央。
Real estate that San Francisco elites had long wanted for white businesses. In fact, two years before the fire, then Mayor James Fielin had hired an architect to draw up sketches for a new downtown. The architect they hired, you may have heard of him. Daniel Burnham. And in his plan, there is no churned down. Burnham was a proponent of the city beautiful movement, an urban planning philosophy popular in the late 19th and early 20th centuries.
旧金山精英们长期以来一直垂涎于这片房地产，用来发展白人商业。事实上，在大火发生前两年，时任市长詹姆斯·费伦就曾聘请一位建筑师为新市中心绘制草图。他们聘请的那位建筑师，你可能听说过他。丹尼尔·伯纳姆。在他的规划中，没有中国城。伯纳姆是“城市美化运动”的支持者，这是一种在19世纪末和20世纪初流行的城市规划哲学。
And this idea of city beautiful, it's very racialized this view, and the idea is a more beautiful urban environment creates a more beautiful citizen Like we want a beautiful city of well-educated citizens and everyone is white and productive and with Chinatown Burned to the ground city leaders seized the chance to make that white dream a reality Within a week of the fire city City Hall created a committee dedicated solely to relocating Chinatown. The group included former mayor James Fielin, the one who had hired Burnham to draw up those revised drafts of San Francisco. And so the minute the city goes up in flames, I'm not kidding, I don't think the city's finished burning. and James Phelan is telegraphing. Dana Burnham, send more reports immediately, get them to the hands of the city leaders
而“城市美化”这个概念，这种观点带有非常强烈的种族色彩，其理念是更美丽的城市环境会造就更美丽的公民。就像我们想要一个拥有受过良好教育的公民的美丽城市，每个人都是白人且富有成效。随着中国城被烧为平地，城市领袖们抓住了将这个白人梦想变成现实的机会。在大火发生后的一周内，市政府成立了一个专门致力于迁移中国城的委员会。该小组成员包括前市长詹姆斯·费伦，也就是那个雇佣伯纳姆起草旧金山修改版草图的人。所以，就在这座城市陷入火海的那一刻，我没有开玩笑，我认为这座城市还没烧完，詹姆斯·费伦就在给丹尼尔·伯纳姆发电报：立刻发送更多报告，把它们交到城市领袖
and business leaders. Here's our plan, we can rebuild. Here's the perfect city. The plan for that perfect city booted the Chinese all the way to Hunter's Point, a region on the edge of town. It's where the city's slaughterhouses were. But it wasn't long before the Chinese residents
和商界领袖手中。这是我们的计划，我们可以重建。这是最完美的城市。那个完美城市的计划把中国人生生赶到了汉特角，一个位于城镇边缘的地区。那是该市屠宰场所在地。但没过多久，中国居民
found out about the plan. And they fought back, and I think they fought back very intelligently. They got China's Empress Dowager Sushi involved. She sent her council general from Washington to meet with San Francisco officials. But the coup de Gras was financial. For decades, San Francisco had been a key hub for trade with China.
就发现了这个计划。他们进行了反击，而且我认为他们的反击非常聪明。他们拉上了中国的慈禧太后。她派了她驻华盛顿的总领事与旧金山官员会面。但致命的一击是财务上的。几十年来，旧金山一直是与中国贸易的关键枢纽。
So, a group of the city's top Chinese business owners wrote to the current mayor in a language San Francisco officials could easily understand. And so, on the business level that the negotiation was, okay, you don't want us to come back. We're not going to Hunter's Point. We can go to Tacoma, we can go to Portland, so there's a panic of a loss of revenue for the city.
于是，该市的一群顶尖华人企业主写信给现任市长，用旧金山官员能够轻易理解的语言。因此，在商业层面的谈判是，好吧，你们不想让我们回来。我们不会去汉特角。我们可以去塔科马，我们可以去波特兰，所以城市会陷入税收流失的恐慌中。
And that was a loss that city leaders couldn't take. Less than a month after the quake, the mayor dissolved his committee to relocate Chinatown. For Chinese Americans at this time, this was an unprecedented political victory, but they didn't stop there. The fire had left Chinatown a blank slate, and for the first time, the Chinese were holding
那是城市领袖无法承受的损失。地震发生不到一个月后，市长解散了他负责迁移中国城的委员会。对于当时的美国华人来说，这是一场前所未有的政治胜利，但他们并没有就此罢休。大火给中国城留下了一张白纸，而这一次，中国人掌握了
the chalk. They were sick of Chinatown getting this bad rap for vice, sick of city hall harassing them, sick of visitors asking them if they lived in tunnels. The Chinese wanted a makeover for their neighborhood, and an American born Chinese businessman named Luk Tin Eli knew just how to go about it. The word was build me a pagoda. That's Felicia Lowe again. She says that Luk Tin Eli figured, hey, if tourists are always going to come to Chinatown seeking a taste of some imaginary East, let's give them what they want.
粉笔。他们受够了中国城因恶名而背上的黑锅，受够了市政府的骚扰，受够了游客询问他们是否住在隧道里。中国人想要为他们的社区进行大改造，而一个名叫陆锦才（Luk Tin Eli）的美籍华商深知该如何着手。口号就是：给我建一座宝塔。那是菲利西亚·洛的又一次发言。她说陆锦才心想，嘿，既然游客总是要来中国城寻求对某个想象中的东方的体验，那就满足他们的愿望吧。
And so he was able to hire white architects to create a Chinatown that looked the way white people imagined Chinatown to look, even though he knew in his own mind that the buildings in China didn't all look like this. Now looks plan might seem a bit counterintuitive at first. For decades, the Chinese of San Francisco had been harassed precisely because they looked and dressed differently from mainstream white America. And here was a guy saying, let's rebuild our neighborhood in a way that emphasizes our foreignness, that carves our difference from the rest of the city into the very face of our buildings. Papani Soy, whose father had been flummoxed by the look of Chinatown when he arrived in San
因此，他得以雇佣白人建筑师来建造一个符合白人想象中中国城模样的中国城，尽管他内心深知中国的建筑并不全都是这个样子的。现在，陆的计划起初可能看起来有点违反直觉。几十年来，旧金山的华人一直受到骚扰，恰恰是因为他们的外表和穿着与主流白人美国人不同。而这里却有一个家伙说，让我们以强调我们异国情调的方式重建我们的社区，将我们与城市其他部分的差异刻在我们建筑的表面上。邦妮·崔，其父亲在抵达旧金山时曾对中国城的样貌感到困惑，
Francisco, she says that the Chinese community of 1907 saw a positive side to that foreignness. And they also were pretty savvy with the fact that people were interested in them and they were interested in this exotic element and if they could build that in a way that was attractive instead of repellent that that would be protective for them. Look hired an architect named T. Patterson Ross and an engineer named AW Burger. These two men had never been to China. At the time, the architects were not trained in the tradition or anything about Oriental architecture because also at that time the Oriental was considered way behind the west. So culturally, everything was looked down upon, let's say, it's nothing to study about.
她表示，1907年的华人社区看到了这种异国情调积极的一面。“而且他们也非常精明地意识到，人们对他们很感兴趣，对这种异国情调很感兴趣，如果他们能以一种吸引人而不是排斥人的方式来建造它，那将对他们起到保护作用。”陆雇佣了一位名叫T·帕特森·罗斯的建筑师和一位名叫A·W·伯格的工程师。这两个人从来没去过中国。当时，建筑师们没有接受过东方建筑传统或任何方面的培训，因为在那个时期，东方也被认为远远落后于西方。所以在文化上，一切都被看不起，可以说，没有什么好研究的。
Ross and Bergerin's knowledge of China was limited to a few images they'd seen of ancient palaces from the Song Dynasty. An architectural style that was already hundreds of years old by the early 20th century. But that didn't stop Ross and Bergerin from using their imaginations, and oh, how they used their imaginations. They created the sort of a Disney land effect.
罗斯和伯格对中国的了解仅限于他们看到的几张宋代古代宫殿的图片。这种建筑风格在20世纪初已经有几百年的历史了。但这并没有阻止罗斯和伯格发挥他们的想象力，哦，他们是如何发挥想象力的啊。他们创造了一种类似迪士尼乐园的效果。
For instance, the Sing Chong building was top with a small structure that sort of looked like a pagoda. But choice says that in China, you typically wouldn't see a pagoda on top of another building. pagoda's there are free-standing structures, not a decorative flourish. And secondly, In China, these were monuments for religious purposes, the religion of Buddhism. Here in its San Francisco form,
例如，兴昌大楼的顶端是一个类似于宝塔的小结构。但崔说，在中国，你通常不会看到宝塔建在另一栋建筑的顶上。那里的宝塔是独立的建筑，而不是装饰性的繁复花纹。其次，在中国，这些是用于宗教目的的纪念碑，即佛教。在这里的旧金山版本中，
the pagoda instead houses a monument to consumerism. Sing Chong became a bustling department store, Hawking Asian Art, which it still is to this day. But nonetheless, the designers that looked 10 Eli Hired created a striking building, and other merchants rebuilding in Chinatown couldn't help but notice. Soon, Sing Chang's bombastic Shinwazari look had become the style for most new structures going up in Chinatown. The architects who were trying to reproduce Beijing in San Francisco may
宝塔反而成了消费主义纪念碑的所在地。兴昌百货变成了一家出售亚洲艺术品的繁华百货公司，至今仍然如此。尽管如此，陆锦才雇佣的设计师们建造了一座引人注目的建筑，其他在中国城重建的商人也注意到了这一点。很快，兴昌百货那种浮夸的“中国风”外观成了中国城大多数新建结构的标准风格。那些试图在旧金山复制北京的建筑师们可能
have gotten a lot of the details wrong. But for the Taurus, they were wrong in all the right ways. Taurus loved the new Chinatown. This was exactly the westerner friendly version of China they wanted, vaguely exotic, but safe enough for a middle-class white America. The visitors began to flow into Chinatown, and so did their cash. In Chinatown's pleasant new appearance was beginning to change popular sentiment towards the Chinese people. American newspapers made it explicit that the neighborhood makeover was causing them to rethink their contempt for the Chinese. As one newspaper, the bulletin put it in 1909, quote, China Town is one of the most noted places on the American continent.
把很多细节都弄错了。但对游客来说，他们错得恰到好处。游客们喜欢这个新中国城。这正是他们想要的那个对西方人友好的中国版本，带有模糊的异国情调，但对中产阶级白人美国人来说又足够安全。游客们开始涌入中国城，他们的现金也随之而来。中国城令人愉悦的新面貌开始改变公众对中国人的情绪。美国报纸明确表示，社区的大改造让他们重新思考了对中国人的蔑视。正如《公报》在1909年的一篇报道中所说，引述：“中国城是美洲大陆最著名的地点之一。
We have held up to the public gaze for too long the racial grief that separates the yellow and white people of the earth." Looked in Eli's plan had worked. And Chinese communities elsewhere in the US were taking note. All of the success of Chinatowns that have come in America take a cue from this, take a page from this playbook, New York San Francisco LA, Honolulu. They all sort of have their roots in San Francisco. That's Bonnie Saway again.
我们把分隔地球上黄种人和白人的种族悲剧在公众目光下展示得太久了。”陆锦才的计划成功了。美国其他地方的华人社区也注意到了这一点。美国所有中国城的成功都借鉴了这一点，翻开了这本经书的崭新一页，纽约、旧金山、洛杉矶、檀香山。它们的根源都或多或少可以追溯到旧金山。那是邦妮·崔的又一次发言。
She says the visual style and tourist-friendly attitude that San Francisco's Chinatown had perfected soon began to spread. In fact, the new Chinatown brand was so successful that it's still influencing Chinatowns being built in our own time. For instance, take influencing Chinatowns being built in our own time. For instance, take the Chinatown in Las Vegas, which was created in the 90s. It also had the same pagoda ruflines and dragon gates, like the same language,
她说，旧金山中国城所完善的视觉风格和对游客友好的态度很快开始传播开来。事实上，这个新的中国城品牌非常成功，以至于它至今仍在影响着在我们这个时代建造的中国城。例如，以我们这个时代正在建造的中国城为例。例如，90年代创建的拉斯维加斯中国城。它也有相同的宝塔屋顶线条和龙门，就像相同的语言一样，
the architectural language, the same architectural vernacular was being used to create the newest Chinatown that was used to create the oldest Chinatown. You know, you outsmarted the devil. You know, basically there is a phrase, you know, that they called white people, bakwe, which is the white devil. I think that it was a victory, absolutely. Of course, this architectural revenge didn't instantly fix everything for the Chinese in San Francisco. They still faced plenty of legal and popular discrimination. For example, they were still required by real estate laws to live in Chinatown. And on a federal level, the Chinese Exclusion Act itself wouldn't even be repealed until
建筑语言，用来建造最新中国城的建筑白话与用来建造最古老中国城的建筑白话是相同的。你知道的，你智胜了魔鬼。你知道的，基本上有一个短语，你知道的，他们称白人为“bakwe”，也就是白鬼。我认为这绝对是一次胜利。当然，这种建筑上的报复并没有立即解决旧金山华人的所有问题。他们仍然面临着大量的法律和普遍的歧视。例如，房地产法律仍然要求他们住在中国城。而在联邦层面，排华法案本身直到
1943. More than 30 years later. And even if the rebranding of Chinatown helped to ease negative sentiment towards the Chinese, Philip Choi believes it may also have helped promote certain stereotypes. It continues to promote our fullness, and I remember my daughter coming home one day very annoyed, and upset, is that these people look, look, look, it's like they've never seen a Chinese person before. By contrast, look at the other traditionally ethnic neighborhoods in San Francisco, Japan, town, or the Italian neighborhood of North Beach.
1943年才被废除。三十多年后。即使中国城的品牌重塑有助于缓解对华人的负面情绪，菲利普·崔认为，这也可能助长了某些刻板印象。“它继续宣扬我们的异国情调，我记得我女儿有一天回家时非常恼火和沮丧，说这些人看啊看啊，就好像他们从来没见过中国人一样。”相比之下，看看旧金山其他传统的族裔社区，日本城，或者意大利社区北滩。
Choices, those neighborhoods didn't self-exoticize in the 1900s to nearly the same extent that China counted. They deliberately not embellish and embrace the ethnicity. Other immigrant groups at that time didn't face the same antagonism that the Chinese did. So only the Chinese were forced to cater to white people's fantasies as a survival mechanism. Well, that's the irony. At that time, we had to promote our forness to be accepted.
崔说，这些社区在20世纪并没有像中国城那样进行自我异国情调化。他们刻意不进行修饰，并拥抱自己的族裔。当时的其他移民群体制并没有面临与中国人相同的敌意。因此，只有中国人为求生而被迫迎合白人的幻想。嗯，这就是讽刺之处。当时，我们必须宣扬我们的异国情调才能被接受。
But even if Chinatown's architecture is a somewhat authentic representation of the real thing, what a lot of tourists don't realize is. The fact that real people live there, and that it is a place actually that is for poor people. I mean, it is at its essence, a place where people come to live when they first get here because they can't afford to live anywhere else, because they need the services
但即使中国城的建筑在某种程度上是对真实事物的真实再现，许多游客没有意识到的是。事实上，有真实的人住在那里，而且它实际上是一个为穷人服务的地方。我的意思是，从本质上讲，这里是人们刚来到这里时因为无力在其他地方居住而前来居住的地方，因为他们需要那里提供的
that are provided there. Bonnie Saway says this is true of all the Chinatowns she studied. They're all portals of entry for new immigrants of a particular class, working class immigrants who don't speak English. In fact, thanks to factors like rent control, zoning restrictions, and really active tenants' rights groups in the community, San Francisco's Chinatown
服务。邦妮·崔表示，她研究的所有中国城都是如此。它们都是特定阶层新移民的入境门户，即不会说英语的工人阶级移民。事实上，由于租金管制、分区限制以及社区中非常活跃的租客权益组织等因素，旧金山的中国城
has managed to remain a relatively affordable neighborhood for low-income immigrants. And Bonnie says yes. Chinatown has been disneyfied and rebranded to cater to American tastes, but there's still an authentic and important history there. There's something about it that if you can sort of read the skyline, you can read the story of how this place came to be, and also in that is Chinese American history,
已经设法保持为一个对低收入移民来说相对负担得起的社区。邦妮说，是的。中国城已经被迪士尼化和品牌化以迎合美国人的品味，但那里仍然有着真实而重要的历史。关于它，有一些东西，如果你能解读天际线，你就能解读这个地方是如何诞生的故事，其中也蕴含着美国华人的历史，
and in that there's like, there's this power in that, for sure. 99% invisible was produced this week by Chelsea Davis and Katie Mingle. A version of the story was originally broadcast in the public radio history program Backstory. One of my favorite episodes and episode titles of all time, a sweet surprise awaits you. Is up next. After this. This is still 99% invisible, and I'm still Roman Mars. It was the night of March 30th, 2005, and the Powerball Jackpot was $25 million.
毫无疑问，这其中蕴含着力量。“99%隐形”本周由切尔西·戴维斯和凯蒂·明格制作。该故事的一个版本最初在公共广播历史节目《背景故事》中播出。接下来是我有史以来最喜欢的剧集和剧集标题之一，“甜蜜的惊喜等待着你”。广告之后。这里依然是“99%隐形”，我依然是罗曼·马斯。那是2005年3月30日的夜晚，强力球头奖奖金为2500万美元。
On TV, the White Ping Pong Balls rolled out one by one as the host announced the winning numbers. 22, 28, 32, 33, 39, and your power ball is 42. That's producer Avery Truffleman. And there was a winner in Tennessee. But the way the power ball drawings work, they're usually some second place winners, who guess all of the numbers except for the very last one. On average there are three or four of these players. But on March 30th 2005, there were 110 second place winners. Was there a
在电视上，白色的乒乓球一个接一个地滚出来，主持人宣布着中奖号码。22、28、32、33、39，你的强力球是42。那是制作人埃弗里·特鲁夫曼。田纳西州出现了一位中奖者。但强力球开奖的方式是，通常会有一些二等奖得主，他们猜对了除了最后一个数字之外的所有号码。平均有三到四名这样的玩家。但在2005年3月30日，有110位二等奖得主。难道是发生了
computer glitch? Step played all the same number, like has someone compromise a system. This is journalist Jennifer Aitley. Lottery officials are panicking you know because like something is up. So the next day as the winners around the United States came to collect the Powerball officials asked them. So where did you get your number from? And each of them had the same answer. They had gotten their numbers from a fortune cookie. They were different cookies in different states, but they all had the same fortune and the same lucky numbers. Very lucky numbers.
计算机故障？大家是不是都押了同一个号码，就像有人破解了系统一样。这是记者詹妮弗·艾特利。彩票官员当时惊慌失措，你知道的，因为事情有点不对劲。所以在第二天，当全美各地的中奖者前来领取强力球奖金时，官员们问他们：“那么，你们是从哪儿得到这个号码的呢？”而每个人的回答都一样。他们的号码都是从幸运饼干里得到的。在不同的州，饼干也不同，但它们都有着相同的签语和相同的幸运数字。非常幸运的数字。
And so it just sort of made you realize how much fortune cookies and Chinese food have become an American ritual. Chinese food along with pizza and the Frankfurter, has been adopted and modified to become American cuisine, rooted in some good old-fashioned American xenophobia. In the early waves of Chinese immigration in the 1850s, the new Chinese population worked mostly as miners and farmers and laborers, and Americans, as ever, were concerned about these new immigrants taking away jobs. And it was actually only after a huge anti-Chinese backlash that the Chinese actually moved into two fields.
所以这让人意识到幸运饼干和中餐已经变成了多么美国化的一种仪式。中餐与披萨和法兰克福香肠一起，已被本土化并改良为美国菜肴，扎根于一些老派的美国仇外情绪之中。在19世纪50年代早期中国移民的浪潮中，新来的中国人口主要从事矿工、农民和劳工，而美国人一如既往地担心这些新移民会抢走工作。事实上，正是在一场巨大的反华浪潮之后，中国人才真正涉足了两个领域：
One was laundry, the other one was restaurants, so these were cleaning and cooking, which are women's work. And thus, they were safe and no longer threatened the American male. And as their livelihoods depended on it, Chinese restaurant owners made up dishes to cater to American tastes. Americans basically like things that are sweet in their fried and are chicken. And that's how dishes like Chap Sui were invented. Chap Sui, the name actually means assorted pieces,
一个是洗衣店，另一个是餐馆，这些都是清洁和烹饪，属于女性的工作。因此，它们是安全的，不再对美国男性构成威胁。由于生计依赖于此，中餐馆老板们发明了迎合美国人口味的菜肴。美国人基本上喜欢甜的、油炸的还有鸡肉。这就是杂碎（Chop Suey）等菜肴的发明过程。杂碎，这个名字实际上意味着各种各样的碎片，
like odds and ends. Oh, Chap Sui's the biggest culinary joke that one culture has ever played on another. Chapsuui is not a real Chinese dish at all. It's as American as Apple Pie, and speaking of Apple Pie. Americans want dessert because we are American and we like things which are sweet and fatty, so you need it to dessert. And as Chinese desserts go, there aren't that many options that the American palette would
就像零星杂物一样。哦，杂碎是一个文化对另一个文化开过的最大的烹饪玩笑。杂碎根本不是真正的中国菜。它像苹果派一样美式，说到苹果派。美国人想要甜点，因为我们是美国人，我们喜欢甜的和油腻的东西，所以你需要甜点。至于中式甜点，美国人的味蕾能够接受的选择其实并没有那么多。
go for. The Chinese desserts are like, there is the mooncake, which tastes and looks like a hockey puck, but there's not a lot of stuff. And so around the 1920s, the fortune cookie somehow enters the American Chinese restaurant culture, where they came from originally is a bit of a mystery, but we'll get to that. First, let's make this perfectly clear.
中式甜点就像，有月饼，它的味道和外表都像一个冰球，但并没有太多东西。所以在20世纪20年代左右，幸运饼干不知怎么地进入了美式中餐文化中，它们最初从哪里来有点神秘，但我们会讲到这一点。首先，让我们把这一点说清楚。
The cookies are not from China. I don't know why, but Chinese they don't eat a version of cookies. Steven Yang is founder of Yang's fortunes incorporated in San Francisco. Chinese people in China don't eat fortune cookies, but Americans consume billions of them, which means great business for Steven, because he prints a lot of the paper fortunes that go inside fortune cookies.
这些饼干不是来自中国的。我不知道为什么，但中国人根本不吃某种版本的饼干。史蒂芬·杨（Steven Yang）是旧金山杨氏财富有限公司的创始人。中国的中国人不吃幸运饼干，但美国人每年消耗数十亿个，这意味着史蒂芬的生意兴隆，因为他印刷了大量夹在幸运饼干里面的纸条。
Including all the fortunes for Panda Express, that's definitely Stephen's biggest client. Stephen's tiny warehouse in San Francisco's Dog Patch District is filled with boxes. All stuffed full of tiny strips of fortune paper. Each box contains 300,000 paper fortunes. I've been a lot, you see? And Stephen prints all these boxes and boxes with only five other employees. And Lisa, Stephen's daughter, writes all the fortunes. When I visited, she was away on maternity leave, but she has written most of the company's
包括熊猫快餐的所有签语，那绝对是史蒂芬最大的客户。史蒂芬位于旧金山狗补丁区的小仓库里堆满了盒子。里面全塞满了小纸条。每个盒子包含30万张签语纸。“我已经印了很多，看到了吗？”史蒂芬和仅仅其他五名员工一起印刷了所有这些大大小小的盒子。莉萨，史蒂芬的女儿，写下了所有的签语。我去拜访时，她正在休产假，但她已经写了公司绝大部分的
5,000 unique fortunes. This is amazing, because when you think about it, fortunes are deceptively difficult to write. The messages have to be really, really generic, because they could be for anyone. You can't write messages like, you won't meet a tall, dark stranger, because an eight-year-old could read that and be like, I don't want that! Why would we? Infortunes also have to be careful not to offend.
5000条独特的签语。这太神奇了，因为仔细想想，签语写起来其实出奇地困难。这些信息必须非常非常通用，因为它们可能适合任何人。你不能写这样的信息：“你不会遇到一个高大、黑发的陌生人”，因为一个八岁的孩子读到这个可能会觉得：“我才不要那个！”我们为什么要呢？签语还必须注意不要冒犯别人。
Famously, there was once a fortune that said, lighten up, and a lot of customers were like, is this cookie calling me fat? And of course, no bad predictions. Americans liked their fortunes sunny. So fortunes tend to be vague or just generally uplifting like tomorrow will be better. Or the fortunes are nabbed from quotation books just whatever Lisa can find. Steven doesn't really care. He doesn't read them. But I don't know why. I make people they like it. They say they
有句著名的签语曾写着“放轻松点”，很多顾客觉得：“这是这块饼干在叫我胖子吗？”当然，不能有不好的预测。美国人喜欢积极向上的签语。因此，签语往往含糊不清，或者只是普遍振奋人心，比如明天会更好。或者这些签语是从名言警句集中摘录的——只要是莉萨能找到的。史蒂芬其实并不在乎。他不读这些。但我不懂为什么。我让人制作它们，他们挺喜欢的。他们说
will do when they got a fortune after eating dinner, they were keeping the words. They keep them. Yeah, it's true. Some people do keep the fortunes in their wallets. When I asked around, it turns out a few of my friends do this, or can recite their favorite fortunes for memory. And it's crazy because a lot of these fortunes are Stevens, written by his daughter, Lisa.
吃完晚饭拿到签语时，他们会把上面的话留着。他们会把它们留下来。是的，这是真的。有些人确实把签语放在钱包里。当我四处打听时，发现我的几个朋友也这样做，或者能凭记忆背出他们最喜欢的签语。这很疯狂，因为这些签语很多都是史蒂芬的，由他的女儿莉萨编写。
But there are a few ways to tell where your fortunes come from. If you get one with blue corners on it, that was printed by a giant company in New York called Wonton Food. They make over 4 million cookies a day and were responsible for the cookie that made all those powerball winners in 2005. If your fortune has smiley faces on it, it was probably printed by a Chinese company. For the American market, of course. And if the fortune doesn't have blue corners or smiley faces, chances are it was one of
但有几种方法可以辨别你的签语来自哪里。如果你拿到的签语带有蓝色边缘，那是纽约一家名为“馄饨食物”的大公司印刷的。他们每天生产超过400万个饼干，并制造了2005年产生所有那些强力球中奖者的饼干。如果你的签语上有笑脸，那它很可能是由一家中国公司印刷的。当然是针对美国市场的。如果签语没有蓝色边缘或笑脸，那它很可能是由史蒂芬印刷的成千上万条中的一条——采用各种不同的颜色和字体——并发送到全国各地的工厂，包括旧金山中国城一个小巷里的金门幸运饼干公司。金门幸运饼干公司非常具有旅游景点的特色。
the many thousands that Steve and Pritz, in all different colors and fonts, and sends to factories all over the country, including the Golden Gate Fortune Cookie Company, in a tiny alleyway in San Francisco is Chinatown. The Golden Gate Fortune Cookie Company is pretty touristy. It charges visitors 50 cents a photo and doesn't actually have a very big cookie output. Actually calling this place a factory is kind of an overstatement. It's just one narrow room with most of the space taken up by three hulking fortune cookie machines.
它向游客收取每张照片50美分的费用，实际上饼干产量并不算很大。事实上，把这个地方叫做工厂有点夸张。它只是一个狭窄的房间，大部分空间都被三台笨重的幸运饼干机器占据了。
Versions of machines that were invented by Edward Louis. My father used to call his machine like his fourth child. He had three sons and then the fourth was his baby. Ming Louis, one of Edward's three sons, met me at the Golden Gate Fortune Cookie Company. These fortune cookie machines are pretty simple. They flatten round dabs of batter onto a conveyor belt, and a worker sits next to this belt and folds the hot cookies around the paper fortunes. One by one, my hand. And we picked them off as you see them doing here, fold it and put them on a conveyor. Ming learned how to fold the cookies when he was around 8 years old. The Louis family
爱德华·刘（Edward Louis）发明的机器的版本。“我父亲过去常把他的机器当成他的第四个孩子。他有三个儿子，然后第四个是他的宝贝。”爱德华的三个儿子之一明·刘（Ming Louis）在金门幸运饼干公司接待了我。这些幸运饼干机器非常简单。它们将圆形的糊状物压扁到传送带上，一个工人坐在传送带旁边，把热饼干折叠在签语纸周围。一个接一个，用手。“我们像你在这里看到的那样把它们挑出来，折叠好放在传送带上。”明在大约8岁时学会了如何折叠饼干。刘家人
used to have a fortune cookie company of their own, and it was their whole life. Even during dinner, we took shifts. Somebody eats, the other one works. That's how we did it, you know. We used to call ourselves the prisoners, and that was a famous thing. Help, I'm a prisoner in this fortune cookie factory, you know. Ming's father later developed the next generation of fortune cookie machines, a fully automated version, which also folds the cookie. And because of this technology, fortune cookies are widely available,
过去曾拥有他们自己的幸运饼干公司，那是他们的整个生活。甚至在晚饭期间，我们都轮班。一个人吃饭，另一个人工作。我们就是这样干的，你知道的。我们过去常称自己为囚犯，那是个很有名气的梗。“救命，我是这个幸运饼干工厂里的囚犯”，你知道的。明的父亲后来开发了下一代幸运饼干机器，一个完全自动化的版本，也可以折叠饼干。正因为有了这种技术，幸运饼干随处可买，
and cheap enough that restaurants can give them out for free. No one in the Louis family really questioned where the cookies originated, but it was a mystery that other people tried to solve. People like Sally O'Saaki. She knew they were not invented in China. What do you mean the Chinese fortune cookie is Japanese? Sally Osaki is California born and raised, but her parents came from Japan in the early 1900s. When I was a child, the fortunes used to be in Japanese, rather than the Chinese character. And the cookies weren't something you'd get at the end of a meal at a restaurant. They'd come in a bag, you know, and mostly I know who we got them when I was a child, was we would go see Japanese movies.
而且便宜到餐馆可以免费赠送。刘家人中没有人真正质疑过饼干的起源，但这是其他人试图解开的一个谜。像萨莉·尾崎（Sally Osaki）这样的人。她知道它们不是在中国发明的。“你是什么意思，中国幸运饼干其实是日本的？”萨莉·尾崎在加州出生长大，但她的父母在20世纪初从日本来到美国。“当我还是个孩子的时候，签语通常是日语的，而不是中文字符。而且这些饼干也不是你在餐馆吃完饭后得到的。它们是用袋子装的，你知道的，大多我知道我们小时候是在什么时候拿到它们的，那就是当我们去看日本电影的时候。”
So in Sally's California childhood, the cookies were a casual snack. But if you trace them all the way back to their origins in Japan, you actually find them at a shrine. In Kyoto, and if you kind of walk around there, you will be able to find these Japanese bakers, like grilling fortune cookies. Jennifer flew to Hushimi-inari-taisha shrine in Kyoto specifically to try them. But they're not like the fortune cookies we see in the United States.
所以在萨莉的加州童年里，饼干只是一种随意的零食。但如果你一直追溯到它们在日本的起源，你实际上会在一座神社里找到它们。在京都，如果你在那里转转，你会发现这些日本面包师在烤幸运饼干。詹妮弗特意飞往京都的伏见稻荷大社去品尝它们。但它们和我们在美国看到的幸运饼干不一样。
They're like bigger and rounder, and they're actually kind of like nutty savory flavor. So they're more cracker like, but still they're that same iconic fortune cookie shape we all know. There's actually an old Japanese image of a baker folding these crackers and it dates back to 1878, decades before the first reports of American fortune cookies. One of the bakers that I spoke to thought that fortune cookies they designed to look like a bell in part because their bells all along the paths up into the shrines. But then why don't we eat it after sushi? Because like people were not eating sushi in like 1920. When Japanese immigrants were opening businesses in the 1920s, there was no market for Japanese
它们更大、更圆，而且实际上有点像坚果的咸香味。所以它们更像是脆饼，但它们仍然拥有我们都熟悉的标志性幸运饼干形状。实际上有一张日本面包师折叠这些脆饼的旧照片，可以追溯到1878年，比美国幸运饼干的首次报道早了几十年。我交谈过的一位面包师认为，幸运饼干被设计成铃铛的形状，部分原因是通往神社的小路上到处都是铃铛。但那为什么我们在吃完寿司后不吃它呢？因为人们在1920年代左右根本不吃寿司。当日本移民在20世纪20年代开展业务时，根本没有针对日本食品的市场。
food. Again, like the Chinese immigrants before them, they pandered to American tastes. So a lot of the Japanese families ran a lot of Chinese restaurants. And these Japanese families ran American Chinese restaurants full of chapsuui and other faux Chinese cuisine. and these Japanese owners would throw in a fortune cookie for dessert. When Sally was a kid, fortune cookies were still made in Japanese bakeries, in both L.A. and San Francisco, and the fortunes were still in Japanese. And then something happened that completely disrupted everything about Japanese American
食物。同样，就像他们之前的中国移民一样，他们迎合了美国人的口味。因此，许多日本家庭经营了大量的中餐馆。这些日本家庭经营着充斥着杂碎和其他伪中餐的美式中餐馆，这些日本老板还会附赠一个幸运饼干作为甜点。萨莉小时候，洛杉矶和旧金山的日本面包店还在制作幸运饼干，签语也还是日文。然后发生了一件事，彻底颠覆了日裔美国人的生活。
life in this country. You know, I don't know if you know that the Japanese Americans, 120,000 of us, during World War II were sent away to concentration camps. I was nine years old when we got sent to the concentration camps. Sally and her family were farmers in Fresno. They were summoned to a train station and sent off to a camp in Arizona. You had to carry whatever you were taking. That was a child. I couldn't carry that much. I carried a small suitcase. And I remember my mother took me to a store near our town to buy boots
在这个国家的生活。你知道，我不知道你是否知道，二战期间我们有 12 万日裔美国人被送往集中营。我们被送往集中营时我才九岁。萨莉和她的家人是弗雷斯诺的农民。他们被传唤到火车站，并被送往亚利桑那州的一个集中营。你必须随身携带你要拿的东西。那时候还是个孩子。我拿不了那么多。我带了一个小手提箱。我记得我母亲带我去我们镇附近的一家商店买靴子，
because she heard that when we were going in Arizona, there were rattlesnakes and scorpions. Were there? Well, there were, yeah, oh yeah, he loved monsters and scorpions and rattlesnakes, yeah. In the camp, her parents were given jobs that earned hardly any money. Top salary was like $16 or $18 a month. hardly any money. For four years, from 1942 to 1946, California's Japanese and Japanese American community was marooned in the desert, out of sight, out of communication, and out of business.
因为她听说我们要去的亚利桑那州有响尾蛇和蝎子。真的有吗？嗯，有的，是的，哦是的，他喜欢怪物、蝎子和响尾蛇，是的。在集中营里，她的父母被分配了几乎赚不到钱的工作。最高薪水大概是一个月 16 或 18 美元。几乎赚不到钱。从 1942 年到 1946 年的四年里，加州的日本和日裔美国人社区被困在沙漠中，不见天日，与世隔绝，无法营业。
Including a lot of Japanese bakers and Japanese restaurant owners. My recollection was that after we came out of the camps, it was the Chinese fortune cookie. The Chinese actually commercialized it and they all the Chinese restaurants started to serve it. Thanks to Chinese business owners and later Edward Louis fortune cookie machines, the Chinese American fortune cookie, as we now know it, flourished.
其中包括许多日本面包师和日本餐馆老板。我的记忆是，在我们走出集中营后，就变成了中国的幸运饼干。中国人实际上将其商业化了，所有的中餐馆都开始提供它。多亏了中国企业主以及后来的爱德华·路易斯幸运饼干机器，我们现在所知道的美式中国幸运饼干繁荣发展起来了。
It's nearly impossible to pin the Americanization of the cookie to one specific Japanese-American baker or Chinese-American restaurant. The transfer from Japanese cracker to American Chinese cookie was a larger phenomenon that occurred more or less across California, and then swept the rest of the United States, and then the world, except for China. They still don't eat fortune cookies. Part 2 of 99% of the book was produced by Avery Truffleman. This story was largely inspired by Jennifer A. Lee's book, The Fortune Cookie Chronicles, which goes into even more depths about the origin of American Chinese cuisine, and believe
几乎不可能将这种饼干的美国化归功于某位特定的日裔美国面包师或华裔美国餐馆。从日本煎饼到美式中国饼干的转变是一个更大的现象，它或多或少地发生在整个加利福尼亚州，然后席卷了美国其他地区，然后是全世界，除了中国。他们至今不吃幸运饼干。《99% Invisible》的第二部分由 Avery Truffleman 制作。这个故事很大程度上灵感来源于 Jennifer A. Lee 的书《幸运饼干编年史》，其中更深入地探讨了美式中餐的起源，并且相信
made, they're way deeper depths to explore. It's a really fun read. Check it out. The Great Lelatone provided all the music in this story. Most of the 99 PI crew is on vacation or on light duty this week, so this is a good time to send them a note and tell them that they're great. We are Katie Mingle, Kurt Colesde, Delaney Hall, A. Reed Joveman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sharifius of Sean Rial, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Lee, Taren Mazza, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, in beautiful, downtown,
还有更深的深度去探索。这是一本非常有趣的书。去看看吧。Great Lelatone 为这个故事提供了所有的音乐。99 PI 团队的大多数成员这周都在休假或值轻班，所以现在是给他们写便条告诉他们他们很棒的好时机。我们有 Katie Mingle、Kurt Colesde、Delaney Hall、A. Reed Joveman、Emmett Fitzgerald、Sharifius of Sean Rial、Joe Rosenberg、Vivian Lee、Taren Mazza 和我 Roman Mars。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于美丽的老城区 Radio Row，
Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find more at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But did you know that we have a website? And it's great, and it has all kinds of interesting design stories on it? Well, now you do.
加利福尼亚州奥克兰。99% Invisible 是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的坚定的独立集体。请访问 radiotopia.fm 了解更多信息。您可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并加入有关该节目的讨论。您可以在 Twitter 上 @ Roman Mars 或 @ 99PI org 给我发推文。我们在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上也都有账号。但你知道我们有一个网站吗？而且它很棒，上面有各种有趣的设计故事？现在你知道了。
It's at 99PI.org. Radio Tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 99PI.org。PRX 的 Radiotopia。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。